and this was a big one y I save the the
commentary but we gotta at least mention
it was shown
blade now in development Arcane Leon
third third person the man came out and
said third person action adventure
single player game set in Paris and uh
yeah like we'll we'll talk about the
talk of exclusivity but as far as the
game itself I think someone in the Super
Chat said it earlier I love the music
music I love your man was giving him you
know a shape of a fade he had a little
Blood on the head he was a little a
little shook in the situation cuz you
know who he dealing with you know I I
just thought that was now to be honest
you know for me I'm thinking this is
Arcane we just have to accept it first
person like I and I'm I was willing to
rock I'm willing to rock cuz I'm like
this is Arcane when dingga came out
there was like third person he was
dressed for it too and he had to bro he
had to tr he was dressed for it to and
then to see Marvel the rep was like we
love everything arane does we love this
we love death Loop what was Y what was y
feeling why didn't he say
rful that's Arcanos we love everything
Arcane does except that Leon what he
talking Leon but uh yeah then and then I
don't know if y'all caught with Dinger
he said um it meant a lot to him because
obviously he is of mixed background and
that Blaze story is obviously half
vampire half you
from from from Paris he doing it for the
culture for the city what was y'all
thinking of the blade joint
man this well
brev that's not Paris let you
out listen listen I'm uncultured
anyway now I thought well what what I
don't like about my DMs is it was
spoiled already for me yeah the streets
going to it now it's about what is it
going to be
right now it's just confirmation then
when I saw it I saw the confirmation to
it and I was just like this is it y'all
y'all scream you kicked y begged y cried
you needed a superhero game when the
King was saying y'all didn't need one I
don't know why y' doing this and to see
the reception of it for that's what I
said that's big for you that's big cuz I
know you you've been yeah no I got I got
to respect that I respect that from you
that's big from you cuz I know we've had
this debate yeah because I was I was on
another fence that we don't need it n
but um obviously it's necessary and it's
needed but what's even crazier it is so
needed that the
opposition is in denial so you got to
know the property must have hit right
and it must have been a great time to
drop that trailer at that moment that
they they did because the opposition is
Port begging for it right now poor big
no you know why you know why I'm I'mma
find exactly what port beging is and
shout out to my man Christopher oh you
on
fres this is you putting this up Port
begging and I'm like come on and it said
new profile pick he changed his profile
pick to portb oh man and then one dude
put to Phil Phil put something he was on
vacation and he was like the first signs
of snow and the dude put please let's
get blade for PlayStation 5 oh well we
talking about it now that King already
opened the subject up um did y'all see
greedy's tweet of um it it was yeah it
was that go go the Xbox let me see you
got that hold on hold on let me let me
this is this is Christopher Hart right
now no go to go to GRE go to go to my
time line go to I you follow Dinger and
Dinger retweeted what greeny said and
greeny had a very when Chris har got
that picture from what he altered is
originally something that greedy put up
so he was F gazy with his yeah basically
he he edited what greedy put up because
greedy put up play Xbox yeah Jo and
dingo retweeted it it's kind of
interesting how quick greeny removed
profile picture it's like someone PR
message him like what are you doing we
ain't supposed to do that yeah so let's
talk about the controversy adct in the
sense that you know obviously the talk
about it people were excited but what
platform is it why hasn't Xbox
explicitly said this is um you know an
exclusive we noticed the Xbox account
didn't tweet it was the Bethesda account
that tweeted it was coming out you know
um there was one article sh Central but
then they did kind that said it was
exclusive talk about this one right here
right yeah there you go the real one
right yeah
yeah there you go there you go we got it
in 4k you know what I'm saying so um
yeah so what what do you guys think
about that whole situation and so I
don't know if I got a chance to your
thought about the game also include
everything in that because I was curious
to see where you were at an addict I
think I think this is all Microsoft's
fault it's just
like there's but there's too much
inconsistency with their messaging it's
like you
know if I remember correctly and maybe
you guys can vouch or not after the
Bethesda thing was done you know and he
came out because hellblade was supposed
to be a multiplat AOW was supposed to be
a multiplat Elder Scrolls was supposed
to be a multiplat when they did that
Trinity thing when they did that that
couch thing with the Bethesda oh right
right right and Phil just came out
openly said look we bought this to value
our consoles at the end of the day it's
going to be a case by case on what goes
I I do feel like I remember seeing
people when the ABK deal was first
announced where it was like people
automatically assumed it was exclusive
like I remember that's people saying a
fact that was a fact it's going to go
just like Bethesda these games are going
to be exclusive but but the thing is is
when you consistently change up the
messaging you have where this game's an
exclusive this game's not an exclusive
and then you have the the CFO a couple
week ago they're talking about multiplat
this multiplat that Stewart comments
good point I don't blame people for for
being skeptical if the game's exclusive
or not exclusive now I think if you
actually paying attention in the
industry you should know if it's an
exclusive or not let's go off of what
Microsoft's actually doing Microsoft has
not formally announced that Indiana
Jones is an exclusive but guess what we
know that because of the FTC well let me
ask you this let me because you you you
on some fine with some stuff um do you
think cuz this is another trail of
thought right now I don't know if y'all
know the FTC that's what I was going to
say okay they are still battling
Microsoft right now I'm not on your
joint but I'm in
agreement that was funny yeah that was
crazy cuz you always catch me when I'm
out of pocket catch
you cuz you set me up last week it was
good it was good you f that was funny it
was funny so yeah they still fighting
the FTC over the activist blizard deal
shout out to Tom waren fighting and they
said FTC is appealing The District
Court's decision not to block ABK you
know the whole bit and that um they
saying in the appeal Microsoft is
threatening the cycle FTC claims that
they're threatening the cycle of
investment and Entrepreneurship that
drives America's Innovation economy and
then continue to go through the
administrative process so their whole
mindset is that you know they take games
and make an exclusive going against the
Entre Spirit that's a valid thing do we
think that this is part of the reasoning
why hey let's not reveal it now with a
logo let things play out because the
game ain't going to come out too long
anyway they going to know later any I
think Microsoft is waiting for the
appeal process to end where there's
nothing they could do I think they're
you know put the boat on your neck I
think they have I've been told that they
have been having you know uh meetings
and stuff with FTC but in that case why
announce it because because now the
online conversation is whether or not
exclusive no one even is really talking
about where storyline they can go into
what type of gameplay they can happen
everyone's talking about whether or not
it's an exclusive if it's a matter of
six months to a year when this game's
five years in the making you should have
just waited till you can put your brand
right up on that stage next scenario I
want to tell you cuz I hear where you
cooking I hear where you going um again
shout out to Jess Cordon Windows Central
shout out to Xbox 2 Jess made some
interesting comments as well now what do
you think about this Attic in reference
to part of the we know for a fact
because we we we're involved in a way
that
Bethesda still operates independently
like for example they their PR in the
way they do things right if you go to
Microsoft and you try to say hey I want
to deal with pesda no they send you
there that that's where you so so so the
mindset is and again shout out to je he
he brought this up that part of
acquiring these Publishers right is that
they're still subsidiaries they still
have to operate independently and we do
know right Bethesda does move to the
beat of Their Own Drum and we do know
that even in the what is it the old
documents remember when they had to be
like yo Starfield Microsoft was like you
know put a to use a king reference
delete that uh Starfield PlayStation
joint delete the redf joint right they
told um Bethesda this and but that's
just culture instinctually is really not
that and maybe like they they're so used
to not having to do that type of stuff
so do do you think go there's been talk
about that that maybe that you know his
um he was very outspoken with certain
things and hey the way we do things
versus the way y'all do things and maybe
part
of over here relax yourself the heart of
acquiring a publisher is to allow them
to say it whenever they're ready and
Microsoft says okay you know what we
know it's exclusive but you you you get
to announce it in due time when the way
you want to do do you subscribe to that
thought proc I feel them on that but
there are some things that if it's going
to involve your decisions making us have
bad PR then we are overseeing your
decisions on certain things we've seen
them do it in the past I know for a fact
that they've had differences on how to
present stuff at E3 and we clearly see
who pulled the rank card in that
scenario so it's just like look like
that this this blade thing is I just I
find it very frustrating Cobo put it on
Twitter he's like yeah let me read it
let me read it big yeah okay yeah you
cooking you cooking Cobo said exactly
what ad's talking about we could be
talking about how amazing it is that
arcade Studios Leon develops a mature
single player third person Blade game
instead platform talk dominates social
media and the only one I have to blame
for this is Xbox I'm so so tired of this
so people were saying I got you King I'm
G let you cook I know I'm just laughing
all right yeah he said so somebody said
hey man you know what about you know hey
you know uh that it's early you know and
showing it and then clobo responded he's
like look I'm not the industry he said
I'm an Xbox fan first and last and I
don't understand why every small bit of
criticism about what he's saying always
gets downplayed he said no one is saying
this needs to matter you that's fine it
clearly matters to a lot of fans and
many simply want Xbox to do better so a
lot of people want Xbox to in your words
King to put the foot on the neck and say
definitively that it is Theirs to other
bases let's just say is my
time let add
finish here's my thing it's just like
look at the end of the day the person
who told me the game existed also said
it was exclusive so I'm pretty confident
it's exclusive but it's just like I hate
to see such a huge announcement and I
wouldn't necessarily called bad PR just
not good PR either it's like a lot of
neutral PR where people discussing it
and I'm not the I'm not the type of
person that I don't believe all
publicity is good publicity um you know
I I do think there are some publicity
that's taking away from the core of the
core of the conversation and this isn't
the core of the conversation the core of
the conversation is Xbox has an
exclusive game but all that has been
drowned out by is it exclusive or not
and to me it's just like you take one
step uh forward and two steps back
because it's like now instead of
celebrating that Microsoft finally has a
superhero game uh in competition to
stuff like Spiderman Wolverine now
that's not the conversation the
conversation is is this game going to be
exclusive is that going
and not to mention it puts more energy
behind what's going on in in general
with third party stuff because this is
Bethesda this is not Activision this is
Bethesda they bought Bethesda before the
ABK deal and I understand the FTC thing
and that that that's perfectly fine
because you know why come out there with
an announcement that could potentially
cost you more millions of dollars
arguing with the FDC for years that's
perfectly valid wait for the uh for the
for for the approval thing to go over
wait for all that to go over then
announce the stuff oh so you don't even
want it there cuz it's like why why come
out there show all your bars and say
it's not my bars
though that just makes no sense to me
it's like why come out there and say I'm
putting my style on this okay that's on
you I don't know what's on I don't know
like so what about what about greedy
with the subliminal bars what about
green he's doing that for us okay okay
okay so it's not real Jesus Christ I'm
just asking he ask it yeah Y how is me
saying us not real explain that no I'm
saying you said he's doing that for us
he's doing that for the people that's on
Twitter I was thinking it was just for
show okay no he no he's doing that for
the people on Twitter that's asking the
people that that monitor him now we know
for a fact which I knew okay there's no
reason tweet Aaron be changing these if
this wasn't some kind of fruit to this
stuff so it's definitely he's doing it
for us cuz was going to PlayStation they
found
out at that point Aaron come on man at
the end I just all these years all these
Xbox people been coming at me they don't
need no no comic book hero game talk to
him talk to but guess what Bethesda and
Xbox disagreed with you read read your
Tweet read your speak your
truth because
they truly did not
they would have purs if they truly did
not feel like they needed this in table
they would have armed for this fight
heard you would have heard me give you
your flowers if you was here when I gave
it's just at the end of the day it's
just frustrating that a don't get me
this is still a w massive W massive but
it sus you make it sound like it's not
well I can still criticize and still
give them props I do it all the time
this is true you do true I would said
they took a massive W like a capital W
to a
l cuz now it's like we know what's
happening but it's just like I want Xbox
be like we got blade like PlayStation
does with Spider-Man Wolverine we got
blade this feel it make them throw
console in garbage make them SP I don't
even I don't even mind them showing
games this early I just afraid I don't
like them doing stuff when they have the
hands to hide behind their back it's
like if you're going to come out there
and formally announced stuff announce it
put your brand on this is our it's not
their like that that that's what I want
because it's like because it gives the
illusion okay blade if blade isn't going
then what else isn't going we know none
of that stuff's going over there because
it's just like Indiana
Jones if that game was multiplayer I
would give some conversation to
exclusive talk but it's not it's it's
only on Xbox so it's like now Indiana
Jones and blade is being developed only
on Xbox y s right I'm just going to get
you going but I have to read sarcastic
TS adct Xbox need a superhero game also
adct why you even announce it no it's
it's it's not about announcing it or not
announcing it it's what's the point in
having a superhero game if you can't put
your logo on the box what's the point of
spinning $6.7 billion doll and you can't
even have Xbox on the logo okay fair
enough all right we're going to keep it
cooking I just want to give you your
props though for one tweet that made me
laugh he said everyone that is attack me
the Xbox don't need their superhero game
for the past years don't let me catch
you outside playing blade when it comes
that was hilarious he like you those I
want to see you play that that those are
Cog balls those are Cog I felt I felt I
aspired
that anyway s you been patient I know
you been patient problem we haven't he
wasn't part I haven't talked to him I
don't know what's
going yeah you clean up you knock it out
the park everybody's getting on base
right now when you you come through all
right so so still yeah he he I do want
to add one caviar to the conversation
going forward yes people say it doesn't
matter if it's exclusive it's in Game
Pass I want to add that too is that
right does it matter if it's exclusive
to the Xbox platform if it's in Game
Pass day and day so interesting all
right we'll see we'll see what happens
but uh solve thoughts on blade this game
your feeling and and the
controversy uh so first just seeing it
when I saw it after taking in the fact
that it was a blade game and it was
being made by Arcane Leon you know
what's funny sa's the only person in
this podcast that didn't know before it
happened yeah I didn't know yeah we
didn't talk to him yeah he was on
anniversary mode told you guys a million
times don't tell me I know people tell
yall things in the DM do not tell me
your being surprised when you see this
so I was like I was super excited right
um but then I had to go back and rewatch
The Trailer quickly CU I'm like I'm
super excited um at that point he he
Dinka hadn't spoken yet right so I
wasn't sure about the third person yet
and the first thing I put in our was
like hope it's third person I saw that I
saw that um and then when just let you
finish it yeah when he confirmed that I
like PS is high you get mad when we do
that to you I'm just saying I'm just
saying I love you though you sound like
Nory so much yeah I love I love you
continue he he confirmed it and that
made me so happy so my thing is this I I
love Arcane period this is red Falls M
misstep let's be clear about that talk
about that talk about that but
arcanes the way they design games the
way they think about design the way they
think about combat is very special
because they've taken the tenants of the
immersive Sim and added uh and added
visceral combat to it right so you add
that to a character like blade yeah um
and then you decide to take it third
person boy that is something that really
it's I mean again I can't I can't really
even picture what they would do with it
m all I know is that I have the utmost
confidence in the the only thing that
would that worried me a little bit is
that wor art style if the art style of
the trailer oh is indicative of the art
style of the game with that disqualify
has one because seems very stylish very
high five Rush B no not not to me it
wouldn't but I when you when I think
about how people would talk about this
game in the general gaming Spectrum
somebody's going to look at it right
because you know it's going to happen
somebody's going to look at be like oh
it's not of the quality of a Spider-Man
it doesn't feel like Wolverine it's too
cartoonish why isn't it gritty and more
realistic looking that's that's a
comment I know is going to happen
because I thought it myself and I'm like
I know I would play the game regardless
of course but I would be I've always
said this about if you're gonna and
listen there's there's conversations
that PlayStation just wins in when it
comes to certain things right and a lot
of the place if you think about the love
for PlayStation that goes back many many
years but recent PlayStation that love
that love comes from the fact that when
they talk about AAA games there is an
archetype of that game that has
convinced people that this is quality
this is the best there is correct you
when you look at
a at at an insomnia game when you look
at the last of us when you look at a
ghost of tsushima people consider that
top of the top best of the best and the
fact that they've done that now with V
with with um with uh superhero games
right we've seen Batman before him but
sperman with this superhero games stand
in that Echelon now so I just want this
game to have every leg up that possibly
can have without people finding dumb
reasons to dislike it and to and to
shoot it down and I guarantee you
whether it be press whether it be people
on the internet whatever V somebody's
gonna be like I wish it it looked more
realistic I looked it wish it look more
visceral right so just that but at the
end of the day I know gameplay wise that
game is going to hit I I know I know at
the maybe I eat crow in four years I
hope I don't but I listen I love the way
they develop games I love the the way
they think about action and movement and
the idea of hand toand combat forward-
facing combat and stealth right
incorporate that with incorporate that
with vampire like abilities I I think
they're really like Dinka said are like
Coop abilities no none of that no no
that abil are they are they are they
forcing a multiplayer no no not at all
baby it's all blade it's all blade um
I'm very excited for what like Dinka
said let us cook yeah let us we're
cooking right now let us cook um I'm
super excited for it now did you did you
hear a part where he said play BL blade
your way way exactly so that was Arcane
that the arcan of it it's like what does
that mean what does the skill tree look
like what is what what is it what are
your options is going to be in comat
sounds red fallish to me the good thing
the good thing about the good thing
about blade is I feel like Blade's a
very versatile character he can fight
multiple different ways so I think his
type of fighting style and the way he
can go about of combat works good for
Arcane I I'm excited for what they can
do um we'll see what the art style pans
out to be or whatever but um now talking
about the the quote unquote controversy
yeah yeah controversy yeah I I agree
with addict in that like it's like man I
I get all the stuff behind the scenes
and I Microsoft is a company that's
always going to think about that right
but they're also a company that
especially Phil Phil is very much aware
of what the community is saying oh he
got his pulse on the C he has he has his
finger on the pulse he knows what you
know the Twitter streets are saying and
he and he he wants to push back against
that which is I wasn't here to talk
about this topic
whole the third thing and whatever Xbox
listen bill is never going to tell the
Xbox base that they are not going to get
a console and I firmly believe that
under him right him being the overseer
of the whole thing over we're always
going to get an Xbox console even if
it's to their detriment because the
numbers say people you know want to play
xcept whatever game someplace else
whatever the case may be we will get a
console okay so you think sun will be
out before Xbox oh
God I don't know where I said
that just
asking I'm just
asking if Sony goes out before Xbox it's
because an extreme drop of the ball and
no like they doing
now blade why what does it have to do
with blade oh my God I'm just I'm just
messing I I don't know none of this
makes any sense to me continue so when
when do I make
sense we just want Kong it back back
back to that discussion so Phil you know
Phil Phil knows y'all crazy back to
saying this Phil knows that y'all are
crazy he's never going tell y he's not g
to give you he's got to be like yeah
yeah out no no more console for y' y the
streets would burn he's not GNA do that
even even if like you know whatever the
future holds may may be on multiple
platforms whatever the casee may be but
a lot of different things have to happen
for that to be the case right
um the controversy about this I I do
agree with ADD I was like man I get it
you don't I think they I they definitely
should have talked about it here I think
this is the stage to bring it up even if
it's four years out Sony's been doing it
forever and a lot of times when you
think about you know this idea of Sony
kind of maintaining momentum even when
they don't have some stuff going on it's
because the expectation that stuff like
this is in the pipeline right yes did we
need to hear about Wolverine when they
talked about it no but it helps right it
helps so I think that was totally fine
um obviously they didn't say it I don't
think that they're being wishy-washy
about internally this is I don't know
maybe this will be exclusive maybe this
internally they're not wishy-washy about
it even if the messaging feels that way
because we saw that interal Indiana
Jones exactly it was like n this is
definitive nah let's go right so
they know what they want to do for
whatever reason and I think it makes a
whole lot of sense that yeah the FTC
stuff isn't done Lena Khan is not done
with them yet she's fighting tooth andil
nail wasting M tax dollars absolutely
she is they want to run it they want to
run it back but she know she she needs
to justify what she does right like the
scoreboard mad like I'm not I'm not mad
at her cuz she yeah she need to justify
what she do I had to do my shot they was
coming for me I had to get my shot shot
listen I understand them being quiet but
it just sucks because it's always them
that it's always them that feels like
they have this mixed messaging and it's
never like and to King's Point I know
King wants to see the boot on the neck
yes and I think with the showing that
they had they showed like Hey listen
this is the mayor Culp we didn't give
you anything last year I get it here
here you go right and even then and even
then they dropped the ball on on their
last mic drop which was hey by the way
game of the year winner blah blah blah
that was your man
your that was your man in a hot t i yeah
10 man was supposed to do the job he he
apologized he was he was the one that
was supposed to say yeah he literally he
said he said I only had one job was to
get out there accept game of the year
and tell it that it's now available Xbox
and I messed it up so he literally had
to go on Twitter and apologize to X he
had to get back that bread too what he
had to send a check back oh man you got
to get give back the bread that we paid
you to say man I like that K give it
back but again I I think listen the Xbox
base has been battered for a a long time
you know there winds of this nature have
not happened right even we've gotten the
stuff that we wanted as Xbox fans right
you get your Halos or whatever and they
and you enjoy them you don't enjoy them
they underwhelm the general masses they
whatever the case may be you like
getting wins that should be wins across
the board even the biggest of haters
can't can't can't be mad at like you got
to eat that right and when you have this
type of stuff you're like damn the
discourse is someplace else the
discourse isn't oh wow Arcane is making
a blade game what can that possibly be
the discourse is who's going to is
everybody GNA get it who G get it
exactly and it's just like I you know
I'm tired of that I'm tired of that but
but I get it but I I still do think it
was the right move to me the biggest
stage of the year everybody's watching
even the casuals are watching the
industry is watching it time to announce
it and you if you really want long term
to people be to to be excited about the
Xbox brand you have to do things like
this so I think it was the right place
to do it and I'm excited for it I mean
listen man I I don't hide my love for
Arcane I love those games I love the way
they play I love the way they think
about game design um and applying that
to to to Blade perfect character no
doubt King you've been patient what are
your thoughts first on the announcement
the vibe you're you're a Marvel head but
you know you have your thoughts on the
games you love Spider-Man and then
obviously the whole controversy after so
what was your whole thing cuz we did not
get a chance to watch this with you um
my whole thing with these individuals
where's CH at she's inside um I have the
I have a guy texting me about it um my
whole thing is insomniac comes
out says Spider-Man
[Music]
uh Gorilla Games comes out and says
Horizon
[Music]
um y'all don't sit there and say yo
Spider-Man coming over
here y'all just know yeah logo
PlayStation logo be there yeah yeah just
you just
know we're developing this for
Microsoft Xbox
M oh um is it coming out for us
we need to
know no you
don't there's a court case going
on we don't need to give them any ammo
to say see they just announced blade and
blade is exclusive to them this is
exactly what they said they was going to
do and everything that comes out from um
ABK is going to be exclusive we need to
stop this now
no why do you need to know for sure and
why are y'all so weak that y listen the
PlayStation dudes why we got to be like
yo
literally y'all are saying back the
stuff that they're saying to you to yeah
Microsoft needs to put the boot on their
neck no Microsoft needs to announce it
and walk off the stage it's
ours that's it until they say it's
not but you supposed to assume it's
yours oh so you say they not even
confident that it's their they they have
no confidence I seen a bunch of jelly
back dudes we oh got Advance the line
the jelly back dudes is back the The
Mustard Seed dudes you know what's crazy
when dbat got to tweet me m that we need
to get these dudes to hold the
line wait they weak as hell they can't
do a pushup they can't do a sit up
debats don't ever add me in any
tweet and it's getting to the point now
where you dudes are too damn soft like
like what do you do you need the
confidence do you need the Boost like
you don't need it like stand on your
Square listen this is the reason why
they they able to rough you guys up I
got chills right there that felt like
Vel line 2.0 chill cuz I'm watching it I
was dead I'm watching it you supposed to
be
happy Spider-Man got
zero why they got to catch they show
they show God of War Valla which is a
rogue like uh they they fight on the
corner
they fight on the corner with the same
ogres and they switching them out for
red blue and green I can't and he going
to get some Rogue like
moose and y'all guys it's a whole
game hellblade it's a whole
[Music]
game y'all just want the show
win this is this is the this is this is
why I don't like you
dud it's just like y like a boxer who
only picks people that they can beat
M you will never be great never be
remembered because you don't have
confidence within yourself everything I
saw Microsoft dropping that's us that's
us and and and Blake why would I
question if it's Microsoft they said
Legacy titles do he have a legacy over
here there is a blade
game PS1 In fairness there is was it
made by uh uh these D no no no all right
be Bethesda didn't make it Arcane didn't
make it facts and they own and they own
by K I gotta ask you this I got then we
got get addict yeah because part of part
of putting a boot on the neck right is
I'm I'm G show you something that's a
boot on the neck in a second my thing is
like I get what you're saying right and
a lot of dudes come off like they're
scared like they don't believe but a lot
of people want but a lot of people just
want
I love how K is disgusted by but tell me
this right tell me this right I'm going
tell you what these dudes are when you
when they when they come out and say it
directly you the first one R you be
outside with your chest outside with the
chest my chest was outside my is I'm
still is still outside I feel in your
heart of hearts you don't need to infer
anything you know in your heart of
hearts right I get it but isn't it that
much dud is weak isn't it that much
sweeter when you come out and you cuz
you can't say that you get mad when they
come out and if they had come out and
said exclusive You' have been screaming
from the Raptors too okay all right you
know why it's more sweeter like this why
why I get a chance to see people Port
bag I get a chance to see you get to see
the weakness I get a chance to see the
opposition cry for it and so so wait so
you implying that if XBox would have
jumped out and said they had a logo for
the jump they' have tried to dismiss it
yeah now they know not if this hope not
if this hope that come to like yo
Christopher put conversation would have
been different right they would it to oh
it looks whack right so Pro proof of the
tax that's what we doing this is M booty
okay good get get it let he be wait he
wait to me especially like look everyone
here I'm pretty sure we we're confident
that this suck is exclusive
blade we
blading all his 4K Glory going to be on
that Xbox whatever system I don't know
it's be the next system or this
system he gonna be there man him and his
sword everything and and the only reason
that I I was pushing back on anouncing
at this event is because I didn't want
no back no you want a definitive boot I
wanted I wanted shut that like see King
wants King wants wants to go back and
forth with them yo he wants to give them
go back and forth King wants to give
them hope I didn't want no hope I I
wanted I wanted the light in their eyes
that is true kid so so what about so
what about the the the dudes that you
call a muster heart they just like yo
yeah jelly back right we we just want to
put the boot on we want to be with you K
we want to let that no no no no no no
see we want to let the other Bas it's
ours Microsoft could come out and say
this is exclusive okay jelly bags dudes
will always see something well I don't
really like the art direction of you
funny though you know what I find
hilarious King we clown PlayStation when
they don't put only on PlayStation on
stuff and when they put the little
things at the bottom saying time
exclusive ends at this date like we we
clown on them for that we do I don't it
can't happen both ways I don't clown on
them when their first party Studio comes
out and announces the
game I don't expect it to show up unless
it's MLB to that threw me for a loop
right and why why is that the reason
that you don't clown on them because
PlayStation has made it their life goal
to tell you our stuff is our stuff
that's not it that's not it then why
don't you ever clown on them what what
it is is because they don't put that
only on on PlayStation on anything
anymore so why why Ain we having this
conversation with every single release
why they why they not having that
conversation because me personally when
when when Spider-Man came out I didn't
expect it to show up on uh on Xbox
but I do expect all those Activision
Spider-Man to show up at some point but